si paris cette saison avec lionel messi
remporte la ligue des champions août du
symbolisme en termes de technique ce
sera absolument parfait et ils veulent
une fanfare est impossible pour la coupe
du monde 2022 qui est la priorité de
l'émirat pourquoi le qatar utilise le
sport le foot plus particulièrement
comme outil de soft power ici vous
regarde en termes d'argent le fou ce
qu'on dit c'est de l'argent si c'est que
la halle en fait ces pilotes donc si
vous voulez aujourd'hui être affiché à
travers tous les continents avoir une
image et en plus un an de la coupe du
monde et ses rêvés pour le qatar parce
qu'on va reparler d'eux et encore pour
des raisons de manière plutôt mélioratif
plutôt faible
[Musique]
elle a une rien ne va plus entre le mali
et son principal partenaire éditeur la
france emmanuel macron rejette les
propos récents à l'onu du premier
ministre malien choguel kokalla maïga
accusé par et d'abandon en plein vol
après le retrait de l'opération barkan a
qualifié ces propos je suis
2 août
ce week end on attend un rassemblement
des indépendantistes en catalogne quatre
ans après le référendum non autorisées
sont
de la région la tension ne retombe pas
autres revendications l'amnistié de
leurs leaders comme car les scouts
gimont à la justice italienne doit
décider d'une éventuelle extradition
vers l'espagne
et puis au venezuela l'hyperinflation
est telle que le pays va imprimer de
nouveaux billets avec 6 02 -
concrètement cela signifie que le
nouveau bolivar équivaut désormais à 1
million d'anciens bolivar ne payez en
proie à une crise économique
sans précédent
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur arte france le désamour
entre paris et bamako se confirme
emmanuel macron a réagi hier aux propos
du premier ministre malien lors des
assemblées générales de l'onu ce dernier
a évoqué un abandon concernant le
retrait de l'opération française barca
ce que le président français qualifie je
me cite de honte la france qui a perdu
52 soldats dont un récemment maxime
blasco donc au sahel écoutez à ce propos
barbouillé les 6es parlementaires
membres du conseil national de
transition du magny
on ne va pas attendre à la dernière
minute comme ça je répète encore comme
ça c'est parti pour l'afghanistan de se
trouver au fil du mur et
aujourd'hui on a déjà 80% du territoire
malia que donc il n'est pas sous le
contrôle de l'armée malienne alors
imaginez si la france qui est un soutien
depuis huit ans s'en va ou deux nuls ou
réduit ses effectifs
ça risque d'être le sahel distants comme
c'est fait pour le cas au départ dès
20h15 en afghanistan c'est la france qui
décide de se désengager d'une note a2
d'un certain nombre de comptes agent dé
certaines zones et qu'elle avait ce
contrôle où il n'ya pas de sentiments
partis français comme certains veulent
le faire croire mais surtout des
interrogations légitimes au but 2 au
bout de neuf ans de guerre et je
rappelle quand même que la france est
une puissance nucléaire donc apple a
engagé parce ce que j'appelle moi des
bandits de grand chemin et des pieds
nickelés lie la france n'arrive toujours
pas dit encore en trente mille hommes à
plus des forces maliennes et ça laisse
beaucoup de questions en suspens
il est question reste aussi rompu des
gens commencent à douter une certaine
sincérité de cet ajout est dans ce
contexte le mali a réceptionné quatre
hélicoptères militaires russes un
équipement acquis sur le budget national
selon le ministre malien de la défense
il s'agit d'un contrat signé en décembre
2020 est entrée en vigueur en juin
dernier le colonel sadio camara a salué
la fiabilité et le sérieux de ce
partenaire
l'onu a remis une protestation
officielle à l'ethiopie l'instant s'est
réuni ce vendredi en urgence elles
jugent illégale la décision
d'addis-abeba d'expulser cette
responsable des agences humanitaires
pour ingérence dans ses affaires
internes en cause la guerre menée depuis
plus de 10 mois par le gouvernement
éthiopien dans sa région est la plus
septentrionale le tigre est une
situation qui alarme depuis plusieurs
mois les nations unies plus tôt dans la
journée par le biais d'un communiqué du
ministère des affaires étrangères la
france avait elle condamné ces
expulsions écouter les déclarations du
porte-parole adjoint des nations unies
il s'agit d'une doctrine qui s'applique
loeb il s'agit d'une doctrine qui
s'applique aux agents diplomatiques ou
utilisé par 1 et à l'égard d'un autre
état l'application de cette doctrine
haut fonctionnaire des nations unies est
contraire aux obligations découlant de
la charte des nations unies et aux
privilèges et immunités qui doivent être
accordés aux nations unies et à leurs
fonctionnaires
le quatrième anniversaire aujourd'hui en
catalogne du référendum non autorisée
d'autodétermination une date
particulière pour les indépendantistes
catalans à qui réclament toujours leur
souveraineté cela alors que l'an un de
leurs leaders car les spots du monde
doit se présenter un juge en sardaigne
est la justice italienne doit statuer
sur une extradition vers l'espagne les
précisions à barcelone avec clémentine
rang après quelques années
d'essoufflement le mouvement
indépendantiste semble reprendre de plus
belle en catalogne il commémore ce
week-end de l'anniversaire du référendum
de 2017 c'est ce référendum qui avait
mené le gouvernement catalan de l'époque
a déclaré l'indépendance de la région
c'est donc une date clé pour les
indépendantistes et cette année le
mouvement semble donc repartir même de
plus belle ces dernières années il avait
l'air de perdre un petit peu en
puissance et notamment avec la pandémie
et pourtant et bien on a pu constater
que lors des fêtes de la catalogne le 11
septembre dernier et bien
l'indépendantisme était toujours présent
on comptait quatre cent mille personnes
dans la manifestation selon les
organisateurs alors que même en
attendait 100 milles alors ce week end
ce sont trois jours de mobilisation qui
sont prévus du 1er au 3 octobre la
première journée et notamment des deux
aux urnes de vote du référendum qui
était arrivé en secret jusqu'aux bureaux
de vote en passant notamment par la
france c'était donc une première et je
vous propose d'écouter adria alsina l'un
des organisateurs des manifestations cet
anniversaire c'est un peu différente
pour deux raisons la première parce que
on a décidé de faire un hommage à tous
ces catalans en effet des catalans de
passeports français mais de corps
catalans qui grâce à leur courage on a
pu avoir des urnes et débutants de votre
pour tous les catalans du sud en 2017 je
crois que c'était déjà le moment de
faire cet hommage en catalogne nord la
deuxième raison c'est que après la
pandémie c'est très important de
démontrer de montrer à aux politiciens à
barcelone à madrid à bruxelles qu' on
est toujours là que le problème est
toujours là que le conflit est toujours
là et connaît toujours prêts à ce qu'ils
soient nécessaires samedi 2 octobre des
marches populaires seront organisés dans
toute la catalogne et puis dimanche 3
octobre dernier jour de la mobilisation
une grande manifestation sera organisée
sur l'une des grandes artères de
barcelone il faut rappeler que le 3
octobre commémore aussi la grande grève
générale qui avait eu lieu après le
référendum en 2017 et pour béatriz
télégone journaliste pour le site
internet diario 16 le gouvernement doit
respecter ces célébrations comme cela a
été le cas jusqu'à présent lors de la
diada à la fête nationale de la
catalogne un côté là allez gouvernement
espagnol à mon avis doit répéter rsb des
les expressions et les droits des
manifestations populaires
la liaison célébration de la nation
catalane qui doit être respecté et
reconnu dsk prison cela a duré des les
casses et je ne pense pas que le
gouvernement balada guerre mais ce
bundle vous que c'est la hesse comprise
comme une démonstration de force du
mouvement
10 il ya une tendance à essayer de
minimiser ces mobilisations pour la part
des gouvernements je croyais qu'ils
considèrent que c'est une erreur de la
part de nationalisme espagnol faire
ces évaluations des mouvements
indépendantistes les conflits catalan
elle nous confie toujours soulevé un
terme démocratique politics est
surréaliste de la part du mouvement
indépendantiste jsuis sûr et même
diderot et cette stratégie par la part
des indépendantistes et j'espère que
l'espagne se gênera et ne verra pas des
policières pour battre la population
antunez et 88 députés ont signé une
pétition pour la reprise de l'activité
de l'assemblée un des représentants du
peuple le pétition gelés depuis le coup
de force du président unc as his head le
25 juillet dernier mesure
anticonstitutionnelle selon as les
parlementaires appellent à se rassembler
les précisions c'est avec notre
correspondant à tunis bassam chef
c'est une pétition qui a trouvé écho
auprès d'une large partie de la classe
politique tunisienne près de 90
parlementaires tous bords confondus ont
répondu à l'appel de trois députés
indépendants pour exiger la reprise de
l'activité de l'assemblée ce vendredi
1er octobre date de la fin des vacances
parlementaires le 25 juillet dernier
après son coup de force le président
sayyed a décidé de limoger le chef du
gouvernement gelée l'assemblée des
représentants du peuple et lever
l'immunité des députés après plus de
deux mois de plus en plus de voix
s'élèvent contre ces mesures
exceptionnelles qui constituent des
atteintes selon ces parlementaires aux
libertés et à la constitution dont le
président de la république a abrogé une
partie écoutez nous pensons que ces
mesures sont contre la légitimité
constitutionnelle et le processus
démocratique
c'est une atteinte aux libertés aux lois
en vigueur et un suicide politique
menaçant l'état et l'unité du peuple
nous déclarons notre résistance ferme à
travers toutes les formes démocratiques
à ces mesures exceptionnelles qui
représente une menace pour la république
et les acquis de la démocratie
plusieurs députés avaient appelé hier un
rassemblement devant l'assemblée des
représentants du peuple pour contraindre
le président de la république à rouvrir
les portes du palais et de bardot mais
depuis ce matin un important cordon de
sécurité quadrillent les abords du
parlement sur ordre de carthage pour
éviter toute intrusion dans l'enceinte
du bâtiment à la surprise générale à
l'exception de deux députés du parti
ennahdha aucun député n'a fait le
déplacement pas même ce à l'initiative
de ce rassemblement laissant le champ
libre aux journalistes et aux forces de
l'ordre seul participant à s'être
partagé la place du bardo pour le moment
aucune information n'a été communiquée
quant à ce rendez vous manqué les élus
attendent du locataire du palais de
carthage qui réinstaure l'application de
la constitution et rétablisse le
dialogue avec les acteurs politiques et
sociaux du pays le communiqué associé à
la pétition précise qu'une union des
membres de l'assemblée devrait se tenir
prochainement en vue de discuter de la
tenue d'élections législatives
anticipées
le venezuela enlève dès aujourd'hui 6 0
à sa monnaie le bolivar une solution
pour faire face à l'hyperinflation qui
facilitera les transactions quotidiennes
des quelques 30 millions de vénézuéliens
mais pas certain que ce soit suffisant
pour endiguer une crise économique sans
précédent et aussi l'extrême pauvreté le
point avec un cyrielle benavides pulpe
et lyon
si hier vous aviez 1 millions de
bolivars ce matin il n'en valait plus
qu'un le retrait de six zéros de la
monnaie vénézuélienne est entrée en
vigueur ce vendredi un moyen pour le
gouvernement de nicholas maduro de
lutter contre l'hyperinflation au
venezuela un recours qui devrait
simplifier les transactions en bolivars
devenus de véritables casse-tête
quotidien
pour moi je crois que la seule chose qui
va s'améliorer c'est que je ne vais pas
transporter autant d'argent parce que
pour avoir 5 $ en bolivars dans sa poche
en liquide il faut les transporter dans
une valise
donc je crois que la seule chose qui
nous serait bénéfique
ce serait de ne pas transporter autant
d'argent l'équipe dans nos poches rien
d'autre parce que les prix ne baissent
pas il continue d'augmenter
aujourd'hui les bus publics sans l'un
des rares endroits où les billets en
bolivars sont encore utiles pour les
plus grosses sommes les vénézuéliens
privilégie les paiements par carte
bancaire ou ont recours au dollar plus
des deux tiers des paiements dans le
pays sont effectués dans cette monnaie
dans mon travail en ce moment je ne
reçois pas de bolivar toutes les
transactions se font en dollars parce
que lorsque vous remettez une facture à
un client pour des pièces détachées d'un
véhicule le prix varie de jour en jour
même en dollars
donc non on ne travaille plus en
bolivars car le bolivar n'ai qu'un mot
mais tout est déjà dollarisée
malgré une réduction des dépenses
publiques et la limitation du crédit par
le gouvernement les prix même en dollars
ne se stabilise pas la banque centrale
vénézuélienne ne publie plus de
statistiques sur l'inflation mais le
fonds monétaire international estime que
le taux national sera de cinq mille cinq
cent pour cent à la fin de l'année 2021
depuis 2008 ce sont 14 0 qui ont été
supprimées
et pour romain l'aigu c'est une
journaliste et fondateur du site
d'actualité les deux rives les sanctions
américaines sont à l'origine de ce chaos
socio économique que connaît le
venezuela écoutait
tout est lié c'est à ce siège criminel
parmi ces produits ne peut pas rendre
d'acheter effectivement évidemment ça
fait structures non seulement la qualité
de vie des citoyens blancs cea-leti le
tissu économique je vais citer thomas
shannon thomas chamaille vous et vice
ministre des affaires étrangères sous
barack obama barack obama qui avait
formellement lancé le blocus en mars
2015 nous en rappelons et thomas shannon
déclaré en août 2019 dans le final show
time le blocus contre le venezuela est
comparable aux bombardements des alliés
contre dresde est autour 1945 ces trois
cent mille morts un dress de jeu
rappelle effectivement le blocus se
traduit par des morts mais il n'y en a
que ça mais aussi la déstructuration
complète du tissu économique du tissu
social insu culturel ce qui nous
concerne fectivement la reprise de la
production qui est le noeud par lequel
le venezuela pouvoir stabiliser son
économie est entachée videmment par par
les mesures des états unis et de leur
zèle
rennais en urgence à ce sujet de la
corée du nord les membres du conseil de
sécurité de l'onu n'ont pas réussi à se
mettre d'accord sur une déclaration
commune comme le souhaitait la france la
corée du nord a annoncé avoir effectué
la nuit dernière un nouveau test de
missile antiaérien je cite récemment
développé plomion qui multiplie les
essais depuis un mois de quoi inquiéter
la communauté internationale et
notamment washington
et puis cette réaction ce matin du
président de la corée du sud un message
de fermeté de mou jenny à l'occasion de
la cérémonie de la journée des forces
armées sud coréennes sont mentionnés les
essais de son voisin c'est nous le met
en garde tout en appelant à la paix dans
la péninsule
j'ai confiance en nos militaires
je suis fier de notre forte sécurité
nationale
sur la base de cette confiance et de
cette fierté j'ai proposé à la
communauté internationale d'ouvrir une
nouvelle ère de déclaration de fin de
guerre de réconciliation et de
coopération dans la péninsule coréenne
et le reste de l'actualité
internationale en bref et en images le
président intérimaire ne se présentera
pas aux prochaines élections en guinée
ce vendredi le colonel mamadou doumbouya
a promis que ni lui ni un membre de sa
junte ne serait candidat après la
période de transition est les militaires
vont organiser le scrutin pour le moment
aucune date n'a été fixée
plusieurs milliers d'irakiens ont décidé
ce vendredi à bagdad pour commémorer les
manifestations
antigouvernementales d'il ya deux ans
pour exiger des réformes un hommage aux
600 personnes tuées en 2019 par les
forces de l'ordre à des manifestants qui
en ont profité pour dénoncer à la
corruption et le chômage dans le pays
ces regroupements ans surviennent pas
seulement une semaine des élections
législatives irakiennes
et puis l'île maurice qui rouvre ses
frontières aux voyageurs internationaux
ce vendredi le pays situé dans l'océan
indien a permis aux touristes d'atterrir
à l'aéroport de port louis une manière
de relancer l'économie touristique un
secteur vital durement impactée par la
pandémie de colis 19 et selon les
autorités 68% de la population est
pleinement vacciner 4 9 89% a déjà reçu
au moins une dose
la pologne a prolongé de 60 jours l'état
d'urgence à sa frontière avec la
biélorussie cette zone elle est
confrontée à un afflux de migrants
importante depuis plusieurs mois de
nombreuses ong appellent à venir en aide
à ces exilés dans une situation très
précaire et dénoncent leur traitement
par les autorités polonaises le point
avec robin pulls
des migrants ont prié de faire demi tour
depuis plusieurs semaines c'est une
scène quasi quotidiennes à la frontière
entre la pologne et la biélorussie
des dizaines de personnes principalement
originaires du moyen-orient tentent de
rejoindre l'union européenne
mais cet accès leur est barré par les
gardes-frontière son grand ménagement
les gardes-frontière polonais nous ont
repoussés en biélorussie
ils ne nous ont pas battus mais ils ne
nous ont pas donné de nom ni de
nourriture
nous avons demandé de l'eau mais nous
n'avons pas eu ils nous ont repoussés
ont dit ne revenez pas ici retournez en
biélorussie
selon le ministre polonais de
l'intérieur 9400 tentative illégale de
passage ont été enregistrées depuis le
mois d'août huit mille deux cents
d'entre elles ont été repoussées des
manoeuvres jugées illégales par de
nombreuses ong dans son rapport amnesty
international révèle qu'un groupe de 30
de demandeurs d'asile afghans auraient
été renvoyés après avoir pénétré sur le
territoire polonais une opération
contraire au droit européen
notre analyse prouve de manière
irréfutable que leur position est passé
le 18 août de la pologne à la
biélorussie au cours de la nuit et
qu'elles ont donc probablement été
victimes d'un renvoi forcé illégales
renvoyés de force des personnes qui
demandent l'asile sans évaluer de
manière individuelle leur besoin de
protection va à l'encontre du droit
international et du droit européen
l'adoption de nouvelles lois et mesures
visant à légaliser les renvois forcés
sommaire n'y change rien la prolongation
de l'état d'urgence à la frontière par
le parlement polonais fait craindre une
aggravation d'une situation humanitaire
déjà précaire selon amnesty
international
cinq personnes seraient mortes dans la
région frontalière au cours des deux
dernières semaines au chili le couvre
feu après officiellement fin ce jeudi
minuit dans la capitale santiago l'est
par elle et restaurants ont retrouvé
leurs clients le pays était sous
couvre-feu depuis mars à 2020 entre 22
heures ou minuit et 5 heures du matin
selon à la situation sanitaire locale et
cela dans le but de ralentir la
propagation du colis 19 tous les
déplacements y est interdite sur cette
plage horaires sauf urgence médicale on
va écouter quelques réactions de
chiliens forcément heureux
maintenant avec la fin du couvre-feu
nous espérons qu'il y aura un boom comme
on dit nous espérons que les gens
viendront dans les restaurants car nous
avons eu des moments très difficiles
depuis le début de la pandémie mais nous
y allons au petit à petit et nous avons
bon espoir que ce soit pour le bien de
tous
j'aime pouvoir vivre profiter et
partager avec les gens est plus que la
fin du couvre-feu ce sont les libertés
ne pas être obligé de rentrer à la
maison peut peut-être que vous le voulez
mais vous faites ce que vous voulez
et retour en france avec la
manifestation des retraités aujourd'hui
à paris à toulouse plusieurs centaines
de personnes ont répondu à l'appel à des
syndicats pour dénoncer la précarité à
des retraités dans le cortège des
personnes âgées en colère contre
l'augmentation du coût de la vie est
selon eux leurs conditions se dégradent
de jour en jour beaucoup ne supportent
plus leur quotidien ou d'affronter le
moindre euro pour vivre une situation
qu'il considère injuste après plus de 40
ans de travail et péter quelques-uns des
manifestants
ont certes un peu se payer d'aller faire
un voyage pendant trois jours autour de
la terre et puis d'autres crèvent de
faim sur les trottoirs peut-être parce
qu'il ya les élisant présidentielle
l'année prochaine et puis les retraités
ses 17 millions de personnes peut-être
qu'il va faire un chouïa peut-être que
c'est l'année prochaine ils vont pas
gelé les pensions ça va suivre
l'inflation la première vraie difficulté
c'est le pouvoir d'achat c'est le tout
dans l'achat les loyers qui augmentent
nos retraites qui n'augmentent pas
la retraite général et les retraites
complémentaires
et j'ajoute que les retraites
complémentaires du privé
elles vont augmenter bientôt mais en
deçà du coût de la vie mais de raison de
la manifestation c'est se soigner et
manger pour les retraités rien d'autre
c'est pas plus compliqué que ça c'est
des gens des retraités qui ont travaillé
toute leur vie et qui n'arrivent pas à
joindre les deux bouts c'est des
retraités qui ont travaillé toute leur
vie et qui n'arrivent pas à se soigner
on est en france en 2021 et on a le
culot de nous dire que il faut faire
attention à 6 ha sachant que
parallèlement la première fortune de
france et de plus de 100 milliards de
francs tous les jours à venir regarder
ce que tu faisais pas trop dépenser 2
sans parler que quelquefois on a de près
ou de loin de la famille qui est dans le
besoin les jeunes aujourd'hui tombe pas
trop de boulot et bien ma foi il faut
les aider alors je me demande comment
autre entrée en vigueur a également
aujourd'hui celle d'un recours
judiciaire concernant lé détenus dans
les prisons objectif pointer les
conditions d'un digne de sa détention si
sa requête est jugée recevable la
personne incarcérée pourra alors être
transférés voir sa peine aménagée ou
être libérés si elle est en détention
provisoire une mesure instaurée après le
nouveau rappel à l'ordre du conseil de
l'europe à la france le 17 septembre en
toile de fond je cite une stratégie pour
réduire le taux d'occupation des prisons
va en parler tout de suite avec un autre
invité wilfried font qu'il est
secrétaire national du fap unsa
bonsoir à vous il fait fonds commercial
être avec nous en direct sur rt france
concrètement qu'est ce que ce recours
judiciaires change pour le personnel
pénitentiaire parce que jusqu à présent
qu est-ce qui était justement fait
lorsqu'un détenu s'estimer victime de
conditions là un de détention indignes
en
écouter ça va changer pour les
personnels c'est simplement leur ajouter
une difficulté supplémentaire dans
l'exercice de leur mission parce que
quelques très concrètes aujourd'hui un
détenu effectivement on va pouvoir faire
un recours sur ses conditions de
détention mais derrière sur le terrain
quelle réponse on va être en mesure de
lui apporter et bien je peux vous la
donner dès aujourd'hui en fait on en a
aucune c'est à dire qu'on n'a pas de
solution ou aujourd'hui à apporter à un
détenu qui va faire un recours sur ses
conditions de détention et au delà de ça
ce qu'il faut aussi avoir en tête c'est
que ces fameuses conditions détention
pour lesquelles les détenus sont
autorisés aujourd'hui à faire des
recours sont des conditions de travail
des personnels et eux n'ont ni cette
capacité de faire un recours et encore
moins le droit d'aller faire grève ou de
manifester pour demander des
améliorations des conditions donc
quelque part on est en train de créer du
droit pour la population pénale c'est
très bien mais quelque part c'est une
manière pour les décideurs politiques
d'aller se cacher une fois de plus
derrière leur petit doigt et d'éviter
d'aller affronter le problème qui sont
au-delà des conditions de détention la
manière dont aujourd'hui on prend en
charge la population pénale pour avoir
un véritable impact
quant à laure éventuelle réinsertion
mais aussi derrière en matière de
sécurité et de sécurité publique pour
assurer nos deux missions qui sont la
garde à la réinsertion qui a été fait je
reviens à ma question aussi casquette
effet lorsqu'un auparavant lorsqu'un
détenu justement s'estimer victime de
conditions indignes de détention
voilà vous nous avez vous dû faire trop
grand chose parce que les établissements
pénitentiaires sont aujourd'hui dans
l'état dans lequel ici malgré
l'investissement on va me dire les
choses et pas mal investissement qui est
fait à la fois pour la maintenance du
partage actuel mais aussi pour la
construction de nouveaux établissements
mais quelque part hormis de changer de
cellule et à les mettre dans une cellule
dans laquelle on va remettre un coup de
peinture ou éventuellement aller le
transférer vers une autre structure qui
sera peut-être un peu mieux
en matière immobilière mais au-delà de
ça on n'a aucun pouvoir
plusieurs fois et est condamné pour les
quatre ces prisons vous avez vous même
été témoin de certaines conditions
dégradantes ce qu'on pouvait nous en
parler
dit sur dégradantes il faudrait déjà
qu'on se mette d'accord sur le terrain
conditions dégradantes parce que on peut
aussi se poser la question de savoir si
finalement
le personnel de surveillance notamment
qui est confrontée aux violences ce
rachat auger du riz roger est ce que ce
ne sont pas aussi des conditions
dégradantes de l'exercice de leurs
missions quand on parle de conditions
dégradées aussi remettre les choses un
peu dans l'eure dans le bon sens
derrière personne ne leur a demandé non
plus à la population de pennac de jeter
leurs détritus ou les repas qui leur
conviennent pas par les fenêtre de leur
cellule donc il ya aussi quelque part un
peu avoir échangé et qu'il faut faire un
peu la part des choses et se dire que
finalement les conditions
d'incarcération en france sont peut-être
nettement meilleure aujourd'hui que
c'est qu'on peut trouver dans d'autres
pays dans le monde donc soyons un petit
peu raisonnable et si j'avais su alors
le recours judiciaire qui entre en
vigueur aujourd'hui ne va pas régler à
lui seul le problème de la densité
carcérale qui est de 117 % qu'est ce
qu'il faut faire et ce qu'il faut
construire plus de prisons
construire plus de prisons certainement
oui parce qu'aujourd'hui il a une
évidence c'est que roux cruellement
place notamment dans les maisons d'arrêt
parce que la surpopulation pénale
aujourd'hui ce sont les maisons d'arrêt
c'est à dire les établissements dans
lesquels on accueille des personnes
détenues qui sont en attente de jugement
donc les délais au site justice quelque
part nous contribue également à cette
surpopulation pénale donc je pense que
c'est une réflexion beaucoup plus
globale à la fois sur une politique
carcérale moderne pour pouvoir justement
moderniser l'administration
pénitentiaire la rénover la rendent
beaucoup plus sûres mais c'est aussi une
réflexion globale sur la justice pénale
en france pour savoir aujourd'hui quel
est le sens de la peine comment on fait
de finalement en lots le temps de
l'incarcération en fait être utile à la
fois pour le détenu à la fois pour les
victimes mais aussi plus globalement à
la fois pour la société donc c'est un
véritable véritable réflexion qu'il faut
mener donc il ya des états généraux de
la justice qui vont avoir lieu dans pas
longtemps est-ce qu'on va aborder le
sujet on l'espère mais à chaque fois le
sujet de la prison de finale on s'est
pas un sujet glamour donc nos décideurs
politiques généralement il évite un peu
le sujet parce qu'on n'est pas une
priorité budgétaire on le voit encore
aujourd'hui c'est à dire que quelque
part d une priorité budgétaire pour la
population pénale pour laquelle l'avocat
ministre des détenus réussi à débloquer
50 millions d'euros quand il s'agit des
personnels et mama fond nous donne au
départ 2 millions puis après 4 donc bon
à foix yahia il ya aussi vous faire la
part des choses alors la densité
carcérale peut-être que ce sera
l'objet des débats alors à lapproche
justement de l'échéance de la
présidentielle qui approche merci à vous
et wilfrid fonctions internationales
usap unsa effet la fin de cette édition
merci à vous de l'avoir suivi on va se
retrouver dans une trentaine à 2 minutes
rester avec nous sur arte france
et
[Musique]
chacun prétend détenir la vérité trop
souvent il ne s'agit que de spéculations
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous
petits échos positifs n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la vérité les îles